welcome to this video playing max power
from Denmark and Queens gambit as Slav
actually and get to a sloth defense I'm
getting this line which I have played
quite some games with in recent times 3
to be 6 aha hmm okay that's nothing that
strikes me as being very common putting
the Queen down okay okay let's let's see
is this a case so he's putting it there
without having something to her to
exchange yeah it's probably one of the
good good ways to play that's not spent
too much time especially if Knight takes
Knight X there is night c4 possibly
coming
yeah I need to move the rook again but
I'm threatening night see for now maybe
the rook is a little bit worse on e one
that it is on d1 if we consider that
here from before has to move to g6
anyway in the near future
that's weird okay i'm not sure what he
wants to do really Bishop b5 and just
just get to get this end I mean this is
excellent for white get get to bishops
and this mobile porn center how it's
very very nice ok just see 5 yeah I
guess
95 probably a rupee to or should I go
efore first d 493 I'd just go see two
words which does not help him at all
yeah I guess I can push this first and
then we'll be too so it's difficult to
even keep the beep on
if even Bishop f4 now as possible but ok
I'm going to just first attack the beep
on
I'm what the heck v6 look a four-up c6
yeah and then it's got night be five
years unbelievable just about keeps
things together might be five
why this is sick rugby seven maybe rugby
seven maybe a some silly tactic here
look before I mean this is this I saw
but I can I can take c7 rookie one
Bishop ironic see one that's still eat
seven hanging
looxcie to simply maybe Roxy too i Luke
d for Luke c6 should still be excellent
for me
opt for up to 6 57 there maybe this is
maybe why black can just about her with
this sign it would be pretty sick but
it's possible
OOP key one Bishop f1 this does not help
him at all
okay really definitely does do not want
to spend super much time you still
cannot move any of those pieces due to
the multiple pins we should be too now
threatened I just take edge 500 black
resigns or just resigns of course I just
take d6 obviously I can take d 6 yeah it
would have been really frustrating not
to win this after he went went for this
very weird transformation I mean it's
very strange he just just should go to
g6 and this is a normal position and
here are this is this whole concert is
just um it's just really wrong I mean
white white has two bishops super great
super porn structure and I just I mean
this is fantastic position and Knight b6
especially after c5 is just just really
really bad because he has a hard time to
even protect his beep on look be to us
maybe even stronger I mean this is a
disaster this a night up no Brooke be
two is stronger definitely stronger this
is not precise here he can play this at
a five okay okay okay yeah this was a
mistake then this one Nessus is a
disaster i guess rugby seven thats it's
important if i just take here right be
five saves them
so I must play this and now rook see two
wins okay look a one was the toughest
defense I was planning here actually but
then he can play that because of you
that there is this and there is this
smooth check for example or also um if
you want can also even can even take
care but ok this star wins should be
three he probably does not really have
anything against exactly this plan with
Bishop e2 and his this is stuff yes this
is overloaded there is something
something getting lost ok thanks for
watching